that's why they turn into a bunch of
hoes
I love that coming out comedian Bill
Maher mocks people who are offended by
everything committing Bill Maher and
Miss Pat whose real name is Patricia
Williams mocked people who are offended
by everything people go crying and
they're ready to jump off a ledge at any
little thing you say it's the kids that
were raising today they don't work for
[ __ ] we give them everything that's why
they turn into a bunch of hoes and be
crying all the time it's page eight
instead of being honest to kids they
want to pamper them and make the word
easy for everybody The World Isn't I
cuss at my kids and people say how can
you cuss out your kids I said because
when they get into a real world and
somebody says F off they won't fall off
the ground you know Mar is an absent
Mars in the outspoken opponent of cancer
culture and political correctness in
2021 he said liberals should stop
catering to the people who just want to
[ __ ] uh Tom thoughts I I think he's
this is refreshing this is absolutely
refreshing catering to people that just
want to [ __ ] it's one thing to have a
point it's one thing to move the ball
forward on something important for
society it's quite another thing where
you protest for the sake of protests
because what you're really trying to do
is is move things in into power and by
the way there's a direct line with this
goes right back to ESG of all these
people bitching about stuff and then it
goes back and then they're they're
they're executional uh lever of bitching
is an ESG policy I I love this and I
think he's calling it and Miss Pack is
calling it and I think there's a big
thing in here about kids the bizdoc Babe
is a teacher and we have kids today that
are treated differently and are too
sensitive and are incapable of debate
and she is dead on I I don't necessarily
cuss at my kids but I don't I don't cut
them any slack
um they they hear it from me when when
things not right because no I don't want
someone to challenge them or want to
debate eat with them or anything like
that in the real world and have them
shrink back and be you know unequipped
and unprepared
yeah Bill Maher I've said this before I
mean that's my guy if there's anybody
that I think is just kind of nailing it
these days it's Bill Moore I know that
obviously you're tight with Rogan and
that's sort of like who you think is on
Goat Mountain Bill Maher's on my goat
mountain and it's not because he calls
out the right it's also because he calls
out the left and who are we talking
about right now it's specifically if we
want to name names the people that are
doing the complaining are young people
gen Z who
you know are just kind of entering the
real world for the first time and
they're bitching and complaining and
they haven't done anything yet a lot of
what you talk about are the doers don't
have a voice and the complainers have a
loud voice these days if you're 22 years
old and you haven't done anything yet
you haven't built anything yet you
haven't made any money you haven't built
a family you haven't accomplished
anything it's so easy to [ __ ] these
days about everything that you're seeing
in the world and all the plights that
you're dealing with the reality is in
America today in America this is the
best most amazing time we've ever had in
our country as far as living longer
healthier wealthier things are so good
in America and you know just take a trip
to other places in the world and then
come back to America and see if you
still have that same attitude but uh
overall I think Mar is just nailing
everything these days and shout out to
him and his writers because they're
crushing no I mean because I actually
know one of his writers that's on the on
this Real Time with Bill Maher no no I'm
like well but I've done stand up with
him and I just I mean I respect him uh
but it's just uh do you think the shift
is happening because he was so he was
just the Trump
that's all to me because I'm that's from
what I saw in L.A it was just every day
was Trump and like trying to be clever
with the Trump jokes do you think that
this is a shift because he's trying to
still kept because nobody's relevant
when the all those Trump hating CNN we
saw what's happening with CNN do you
think he's making that shift and he's
being so anti you know woke and all that
just because he so he doesn't lose
followers or he's always been this he
said that you know I haven't changed my
positions have always been this it's
been the left the the progressive left
that has sprinted far left like he a lot
of times he'll say this on the show I
don't know how often he watches the show
he says a lot of times Fox News will
praise me right or or Hannity will
praise me or Tucker will praise me in in
the hopes that I'll come on their team
he's like I am not on your team yeah
okay but I'm also not on whatever this
woke ideologue situation is going on on
that side I mean you saw the stats that
he talked about with like that LGBT stat
and how America's coming gayer and gayer
yeah and Walker and woker I think that
at the end of the day what we're talking
about is just common sense he's calling
out the left he's calling out the right
and we need more of that in this country
whether it's a Rogan whether it's a Mars
mother was what pbd and what we do here
Common Sense will prevail and I think my
only thing is too not to bring up not to
cut you off Tom and I do not want to
talk about Trump but the fact that when
uh Dave Rubin was on his podcast they
spoke he still can't admit people like
him that really pissed me up you still
can't admit that what happened with the
elections and all that [ __ ] was
fabricated it was all made up none of
them could just be like okay I was wrong
because even Dave Rubin was like come on
bro like it's all Hillary and she paid
and they're still like no you don't know
what you're talking about that's so
that's one thing I don't respect is
admit when you [ __ ] up admit admit that
you were duped you didn't you didn't
start it you didn't do it admit that
everything that you said that you were
pedaling on your show and all these
people you lied that's what we're
talking about with CNN I would respect
CNN 1000 more if just one day they just
want you guys you know what
we we messed up Hillary did all this she
paid all this money and we believed
there and we pushed it all on you guys
we'll move on that's only that's the
only reason I don't respect them do you
watch uh Bill Maher at all are you
talking to you I just watch his Clips on
Twitter I never watch this show like
watch I don't what is it on HD video
yeah you're not like a bill Mark guy
whatever he posts yeah on on Twitter
specifically Twitter I anything that all
of a sudden pops up first of all I think
he's a he's my style of a guy like if we
were to go out and talk and just shoot
the [ __ ] he seems like somebody you can
shoot the [ __ ] with and entertain have
banter conversations he's that kind of a
guy I like I like how he is but I I kind
of agree with what he's talking about as
well uh all I know is this this year
2024 2023 is going to be a rough year
for a lot of people I'm just saying it's
not going to be a good year for fauci
fauci is going to go from being the
sexiest man on Earth
to a bachelor or somebody that no I mean
he's going to be Scrooge at the highest
level like a scrooge type of a guy
that's going to be I mean you should see
in his reaction when I say what I said
about fauci it's as if I cursed out you
know
yeah I mean oh yeah yeah there's a scene
you have to watch from yesterday's clip
but uh fauci's got to a lot of people
he's not going to be God next to you
he's going to be more closer to a fallen
angel than he's going to be a God in
2023 him Hunter Biden SPF it's not going
to be pretty this year can I see
something about Hunter Biden yeah this
is crazy so I watch SNL a lot shout out
to our buddy Marcelo Hernandez you know
I they did a bit a cold open this
weekend the guy that does Trump uh I
don't know who he is he's actually
really good it's funny and then they had
um Donald Trump Jr come on really no no
no no no no and he talked about hey
partying and I said you know what just
for shits and giggles let me put into
YouTube SNL Hunter Biden because clearly
there's gonna have to be something that
they've made fun yeah one joke crack
process attitudes this that to me was
shocking there was nothing about Hunter
Biden on SNL that is a layup for comedy
100 like you talk about comedians like
layup jokes you tell me you can't do a
bit about Hunter Biden smoking crack in
his den in the face getting money yeah
like you can't do one bit on SNL that to
me is is a red flag so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire pot podcast click here take
care everybody
[Music]